this is the sound of the Colombian red
howler monkey Jorge Ferrer and his
coworker want to know how many of them
are living in the los colorados National
Park the Ranger is fascinated by the
animals maybe it's because they look
like little people up there that are
asking themselves what are they doing
down there if par they protecting us or
wanting to harm us look they're watching
us the park covers just 10 square
kilometers but is rich in animal life
the cotton-top tamarin and endangered
species lives here alongside several
hundred species of birds surrounded by
areas that have been cleared the park is
like an island of dense forest right
next door is the small town of san juan
nepomuceno which is starting to make
inroads into the park over 400 people
live within the perimeters at the
National Park although it's illegal Luis
Ortega is building a house here housing
is in short supply elsewhere and too
expensive I have three children and a
wife my sister-in-law a big family and I
just want a better future for my family
[ __ ] Papa y familia staff at the park
have no plans to throw the people out
instead they're seeking to teach young
people the importance of protecting the
park in samos in the past this area
served as a temple for an ancient
indigenous people for them nature was
sacred los animales all the animals were
like brothers to come on oh hey red with
a Jaguar was different what but I more
like a guy lying heels and they honored
their
with this symbol the people of the
Malibu tribe lived here right up until
just a few centuries ago it's the first
time the high school students have had
the chance to learn about their cultural
heritage yes a look at the kid about we
want to wreak ultimate this to show the
young people how important mother nature
was in the past so that they learn to
treasure it like their ancestors did it
no matter what it's his hope that if the
children grow up appreciating their
surroundings they will later help to
ensure the survival of the park